hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of the 2018 candidates tournament here
we have a very interesting game and it's
between Fabiano Khurana the current
leader of the tournament and the Dingley
Rijn both Fabiano and the ding that
haven't lost a single game yet and it's
interesting what happens it is in this
game as this game lasted well over six
hours I think it was over six and a half
hours and some of the decisions the
players made in such late stages of the
game it really it really shows you that
it's not enough to be a 2800 player it's
not enough to be an elite Grandmaster it
also takes like extreme stamina to
really to really play a game correctly
for for the entire game but before we
start as usual things to Nikki we do
have some photos so here we have ding
and Fabiano before the first move if
anyone knows who the gentleman is that
may that's making the first move for
Fabiano do share in the comments um I'm
pretty sure it's a well-known person I
just have no idea who he is
it's interesting how far beyond of
stares at him as as if he's gonna make a
different move than the one they agreed
upon and we have here a photo of the
opening nothing to it and I do also have
one other photo but we'll wait for for
that one until moved 13 so d4 by Fabiano
although that other gentleman played it
Knight to f6 we have c4 e6 and now g3
the Catalan we have Bishop to b4 check
Bishop to d2 and Bishop back to e7
Bishop to G to d5 we have Knight to f3
castles Fabiano castles as well and c6
Queen to b3 b6 now Knight to c3 and
Bishop to a6 sink after Sundy 5c captors
on d5 and Knight to e5 and here black as
you roll brings the bishop back to b7 as
it's very hard to develop your pieces
unless you do this you can't go Knight
to c6 this Knight is covering the c6
square you can go here because Knight to
c6 attacks the Queen and the bishop and
already white is getting a lot of it a
lot of edge here so after 95 go back to
b7 rook F to c1 and
the knight to c6 and here Fabiano plays
Knight captures on d5 it's not really a
tactic or anything this Knight is simply
attacked twice now from the rook and
from the night here and we do have
actually a photo of this Knight captures
on d5 move a very nice photo from above
so here you have it Knight captures on
d5 and here you can capture the knight
difficulty captures then simply Knight
captures and c6 Bishop captures rook
captures and the white one upon and is
of course better here
so after Knight captures on d5 and
Knight captures on d4 attacking the
Queen
we have Knight captures on e7 Queen
captures on e7 and now Queen to C for
defending the e2 pond and also attacking
the knight on d4 here at Bishop captures
on g2 Queen captures on b4 and now rook
F to d8 first attacking the Queen and
the butcher behind the Queen Queen to f4
defending the bishop and now Bishop back
to b7 here Bishop to b4 attacking the
Queen that's why it was very important
to play rook F to D a to net rook a to
d8 because now this bishop would also
skewer that rook behind so Queen to e8
and now we have rook to c7 and if you
look at this position it seems like
black is black is simply lost its only
move 19 and the f7 point is under attack
there's no way to defend the f7 pawn not
no piece can come into the defense of
the f7 pawn but Dingley unwillingly went
into this and he found a a very nice
defense here King Lear and played Knight
to d5
he simply gives up the f7 pawn but White
has to capture it immediately and he has
to do it with a queen because the queen
is attacked the bishop is attacked and
the rook also on c7 is attacked by the
night here so Queen captures Queen
captures rook captures and now you can't
grab the bishop on before because your
own bishop on b7 is under attack so
first you have to move it Bishop to a6
you attack the e to pawn this was all in
deliverance calculations Bishop 283 in
getting the bishop to safety and now
Bishop captures on e2 and black defended
the material is equal all this world ok
maybe maybe white is a little better
because there's that we suck spawn but
other than that a nice defensive idea by
the English rock to see one Bishop to h5
now kicking away the rook rook to be
seven and now Bishop to EA t' we have
King to g2 a 5h for
offering an exchange of rooks rook
captures rook captures and now g 4b 5b 3
making room for the bishop before the
trip to be - and now a 4 h5 rook to e8
King to g3 King to f8 and Knight to f3
now maybe with ideas of Knight to g5
going for that h7 point Bishop to d7
defending this expanse of the night
can't come to g5 with tempo rock the c4
we have king - king - g7 which King to
g8 to defend the h7 pawn again nineties
935 attacking the bishop bishop moves to
to b5 as this does create the the
well-known barrier for this night so
rock to c5 attacking the bishop bishop
now again moves
we have Knight to c4 and Bishop to d7
night back to e5 Bishop back to v8 and
now Bishop to d4 Caruana isn't
interesting in repeating moves and
offering aggro came to f8 and now f3
King to e7 we have King to h4 knocking
back to f8 King to g5 now h6 pushing the
King back King to h4 and now King to g8
so how can white make progress here came
to g3 King to h7 and now Knight to d3 we
have King back to g8
now rook to c1 a capture some v38
capture some b3 and came to h7 here
Knight the c5 again attacking the e6
pawn bishop to f7 defending and now rook
to e1 would a double attack on the pawn
here dingos for Knight to e7 and you
could capture the e6 pawn but it's it's
very complicated if you capture it then
Black has rook to e
and you will have some problems here
this night if it ever moves then rook to
a5 check picks up the rock anyone but
after Bishop to have to it seems like
you you could have grabbed this pawn
Knight to c6 simply Knight moves you
exchanged rooks and you're up a pawn but
those are opposite color bishops it's
it's hard to say if you can actually
make some progress here
but okay after Knight to e7 Fabiana was
for Bishop to b2 and not allowing that
that tempo on the bishop
Knight to c6 and now f4 rock to a two
attacking the bishop
we have 933 defending it he 5/8 captures
on e5 Bishop captures on b3 now and e
six rock to a7 preventing the pond to be
pushed to e7 we have a knight to c5 and
Bishop to c4 Knight to d7 Bishop to b5
here and this is this is actually the
moment where Fabiana could have could
have gone for for some real edge but he
had to find the move rook to e4 here and
after rook to e4 it's an extremely
dangerous move because it threatens rook
to f4 and it's very hard to find
anything that stops this even if light
goes rock 280 to pick up the bishop you
can simply ignore this still rook to a4
and and and the black is lost whatever
you do you're either gonna get rook to
f8 foul
you're either gonna get night check
followed by Knight to g6 rook to f8
check and then rook to HH checkmate but
there's no real reason for there's no
real way for black to stop this if you
captured it if you capture then again my
to a fate he moves Knight to g6 now and
whatever you play simply rook to f8
followed by rope - I mean there's
there's really nothing to play here I
can simply just check King gauge 7 and
rock to h8 this is checkmate
but here after this Bishop to b5 move
Fabiano didn't find this he went for the
immediate night to f8 check King to g8
and now Knight to g6 okay
it's a similar position but this work
still has to find a way to D F file and
here at England played Knight to e7 and
Knight to e7 is a mistake because it
allows rook to a one and Fabiano finds
this this rook to a one move
now you can't grab the rook because if
you grabbed rook first Knight captures
on e7 would check King moves Knight to
g6 back check again there's a wall here
the King can't approach you tonight King
sorry King moves and simply Bishop
captures rook on a one winning winning a
full piece so after rook to e1 Dingley
rim plays Knight to c6 defending the
rook and here we have rook to d1 came to
h7 and now again missing a great
opportunity here now rook to d5 was
played although a better idea was rook
to d2 again followed by a rook to f2
going for that F file ideas but okay
rook to d5 attacking the bishop and here
Bishop to a4 was played and again here
Fabiano does have the opportunity of
going rook to f5 again winning this F
file and it doesn't matter what black
plays it's it's simply too powerful a
position for white after Bishop for
example Bishop to see to simply again a
knight to f8 check King moves but now
you get rook to f2 first attacking the
bishop and you simply lose this piece
after Bishop moves Knight to g6 again
and it's all over
Rocka fate is again a great threat after
you stop this then comes rook to f7 and
there is no defense against rook
captures and g7 whatever you play simply
lock captures and this is checkmate but
okay after Bishop a4 Fabiano played King
to f4 and now he really gave the England
an excellent the drawing opportunity a
bishop to c2 immediately now rook to c5
was played attacking the bishop and the
night but Bishop back to a4 and here
Fabiano
pushed g5 again he didn't go for this
opportunity H capture son g5 which was
weird for the Engler and because now
rook captures on g5 and now this rockin
g5 is on a very active square unlike for
on c5 it wasn't a very active square for
the rook here tonight the d8
played and here again the England gives
Fabian an opportunity to to win the game
and this this variation is basically the
reason for the title of this video as
the H point SDH
pawn becomes a passed pawn but again
Fabiano misses this so it's very
interesting is six and a half hours into
the game and I mean it's not a tactic
Fabiana would miss the ropes at night -
a fate check and now whatever black
plays it's simply lost if you go King to
g8 now h6 wins the game the pawn is
pinned you don't really have a move here
if you capture the night the night
simply goes even further h7 and there's
no way to prevent it even Knight
captures on e6 checking the king and
forking the rook doesn't make a
difference simply move the king and
there's no stopping this pawn Knight
captures simply Queen comes into the
game King to e7 and now you don't even
capture because of night to f7 he can
walk but Queen to b8 and the pieces are
so far apart that the Queen will pick up
one piece by another another idea after
this night to f8 check if you go King to
h8 if you don't even go borrow yourself
wood picking up the night and then
simply h6 and now the pawn is pinned
from the bishop on b2 and now black
really doesn't have a move this is
simply falling apart this would be even
faster
and another thing after night - f8 check
and probably this is why Caruana didn't
play it he may be thought that King to
h6 was actually perfectly fine but he he
may have missed that King - g4 was not
winning as the th pawn is protected and
you're threatening a rook to g6
checkmate and after and after Bishop to
d1 check King h4 and now be sure to see
to preventing checkmate it only seems
that you're preventing checkmate because
rock to g6 check you simply give up the
rock Bishop captures and now Bishop the
c1 and this is a beautiful checkmate
with the bishop and and the pawn and the
king here as the knight is covering the
h7 square so Fabiano missed this
he played rook to e5 now preparing to
pull the pawn but now simply worship to
e8
preparing to capture that night and e 7
was played and here a draw was agreed
upon so yeah this was moved 67 and a lot
of a lot of opportunities for both teams
to draw the game even faster and I think
Fabian had at least four positions where
he could have gotten a clear win but you
know that's what six and a half hour
game will do do they drool because now
nice to see six and the same idea
doesn't work like before for example my
2fh checking moves and now even even
Rock to g5 preparing h6 doesn't work
because now I simply capture it and
after h6 now there's a problem the
problem is nice the d5 and this is why
it why it doesn't work now if you move
the King simply Knight to c3 blocking
this Bishop so the point will no longer
become pinned and if you capture it rook
captures then comes King captures on f8
and now h7 doesn't work because in that
previous variation there was of course
the rook was an NG five so black
couldn't execute the g5 but here simply
g5 check rook captures and now Rob
characters on h7 and black is actually
up upon here but it doesn't matter it's
it's a draw anyway so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it after this
7 move and a lot of missed opportunities
for Fabiano Caruana the game was wrong
and I always I'm always scared I'm gonna
forget to show you the standings these
are the standings after round 9 of the
2018 candidates tournament and today's a
rest day so there won't be any games
today
nice opportunity to cover a nice tall
versus between a game so Caruana in
first place with 6,000 9 points I would
envious rating performance of 2900 and
10 that's that's really a lot after nine
rounds Mahmud Yerevan second place would
have a point behind him and it's gonna
be probably a game that could decide
first place although it's too early to
tell when mama Diarra will face Caruana
Greece Chuck with five points so
even restric could could decide a lot of
things here Cara Kenwood four-and-a-half
and it would put those two wins he
really got in the middle of the board
Dingley ran with four and a half points
and you know a lot of people people were
saying that after this after they saw
Carolina's position they thought Corona
would find a win there and that he would
eliminate Dingley rain chances of
pulling a Giri but it seems Bingley Ren
is all drawn so not a single loss yet
but not a single win all game is drawn
four and a half points out of nine then
we have Vladimir Kramnik who could have
easily been in the second or third place
but decided to play like a pirate in the
second half of the tournament I didn't
live on Oregon and Wesley Sol in last
place so yeah definitely not and not not
the standings you would expect after
round nine but you know it is as it is
so yeah a lot more runs to gross and you
know a lot more things can happen is
pretty much anyone can win maybe not
anyone but you know it could happen so
yeah those are the standings I do hope
you enjoyed that as well as the game I
would like to thank John vo Dustin
giornata poor and Paulo bernzini for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it I would like
I would also like to thank Nikki Riga
for her photos for each round I will put
all the links to her social media pages
in the description below so if you enjoy
chess photography chest photography feel
free to follow her and check out some of
her work and yeah as usual you can check
to my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon